I've got a question for you how long do
you think Takashi six nine will live I
think it's under a year really I really
do
I don't I think he I just think
someone's gonna kill him like for all
the what he did yeah I don't see how you
survive that and I also don't see how he
gets bodyguards like I don't I don't
how desperate must have bodyguard be cuz
you're he is also gonna die but
bodyguard that's your job I mean you
don't I don't think you have a bunch of
plans if you're a bodyguard you know
what I don't you don't have like a
five-year plan you don't have like I
want to be here then I want to be a
different kind of body like yeah be big
and walk and get hit up yeah stand in
front of [ __ ] get hit by car arrows yeah
do you but with that said with that will
you be a little disappointed when he
dies I think he I'll say this I find him
to be a hilarious cartoon brat yeah in
the abstract you want to talk about a
living troll yeah I mean they living a
live he's like he's like if you remember
that Twilight Zone where there's a thing
on the wing there's like a monster on
the wing in the plane uh-huh it's that's
what Takashi looks like he just looks
like like a little goblin goblin he's a
[ __ ] legend I think dude I mean I
think he I think I agree I don't think
he's gonna live that long okay is that
we're talking about yeah this looks like
some slightly very 83 version that one's
good that guy he's more of like a snow
dude but here's the thing though his
music is good oh yeah that's the thing
as I've never listened his music I will
say I listen to xx Nixon tascioni after
he died and I was surprised by how good
it was yeah I was like oh this is like
there you go
that's more what I was thinking but he
trolls oh yeah well he's gonna have
it's gonna be a unique world that he
lives in because he's always gonna have
to be in hiding unless does he have to
go back to jail do you know Nick if he
has to go back to jail after the virus I
don't know where it's at I don't think
he's out cuz of the virus I think he's
out because of the I think he's out
because uh because he just did he turned
state's witness but here's the thing did
they even bust anybody he snitched on I
think they did they must have I don't
think they I don't think they would
bargain I don't think you would get a
plea deal if you didn't have good
information because that's my guilty
pleasure is going and watching his stuff
sometimes and seeing what he's up to you
know I watched the video he's yeah he's
a he's a he's a tree he's a living troll
yeah but he recently tried to out
billboard he was saying that Justin
Bieber and Ariana Grande paid to get
number one on the Billboard yeah he was
saying that like at the last minute
people would buy you know listens to
their songs or something so right yeah
but I mean I think that kind of stuff
has always been like those charts can be
manipulated I feel like yeah well what's
funny is like the song is called I'm
back and they mad yeah well it's like
yeah you of course they're mad you
[ __ ] snitched on a gang he did lie or
he snitched or whatever but I can't
believe there's so much is there a lot
of like is there a real code of conduct
between some of these [ __ ] really I
think only yeah code at black don't seem
like he has a real code of conduct you
know yeah I think the thing is you're
not the one thing you're not supposed to
do is you just can't sniff you're all
doing crime you can't you can flip right
that's the only I think that's the but
none of them yeah that's a good rule
yeah like none of them have like you to
your point I don't think if they don't
have a code but it's they start doing it
because they're desperate and then it's
like well they made that decision they
did crime because they're desperate
they're gonna turn cuz they're just
gonna
what's the desk and if you're in a
desperate situation he's going to take
the he's just gonna continue to take the
I bet he dies of an overdose
that would be Maury yeah I don't I'm
sure his existence is a form of misery
as like angry and [ __ ] ha it's it's
got to be scariest like your body can't
take that kind of stress
yeah I agree the constant like oh damn
them them like them them them and you
really do have people out to kill you
yeah to kill you someone could openly
say I want to kill you and everyone be
like even the cops be like but is he now
under with witness protection is he
under or police watching him like are
they protecting him as well I don't that
I don't know I don't know I don't think
the cops are gonna protect him but I
don't I've been crazy Graham with the
shame that your identities I'll tell you
what we do here's a question we don't
know this we definitely don't know all
right what is Takashi's please a great
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one